The one thing we know about the future...
...is we have no idea how we're going to be working in 20 years,...
...10 years, even 5 years.
Charleston East and Bay View represent the first time that we led the concept...
...and construction of our own major campuses...
...and it's an opportunity to rethink the very idea of what an office building is,...
...and rethink what's possible for the industry.
With this shape, we've had people walking by and they're like, "What is this?"
Like, they don't even know it.
It doesn't look like an office building, which is so fascinating...
...because then when you come in,...
...you have no preconceptions of how to work that comes from historic ways of working.
But instead, it's like a canvas of creating new ways of being together.
With these projects, we really thought about people first,...
...using things like healthy materials and air quality.
Everyone has natural light and has thermal, visual and acoustic comfort.
Down on the bottom level is really like the market.
It's where we have our meeting rooms, cafes,...
...where you can connect with your community and collaborate.
And then up here, it's more quiet.
You're really focused on that immediate team.